element your words Dennis that the
greatest act of defiance today for
millions of ukrainians is just to go on
with their lives
we have seen how Russia is deliberately
targeting civilian infrastructure
seeking to paralyze Ukraine at the
beginning of the winter and I think
Russia's tactics are very clear
I mean my friends in Ukraine they tried
to break your defense and Russia failed
badly
and now they are trying to break your
spirit but Russia will fail because
Ukrainian Spirit remains unyielded and
Unbroken
ukrainians are trying to carry on with
their normal lives and I think the film
was very impressive to see how
um the images of of hospitals and
schools
keeping on going despite the blackouts
mothers that were heating food and water
on small fires even shops trying with
innovative solutions to keep on going I
think every single person in Ukraine is
sending the same message to Russia
ukrainians Are Not Afraid ukrainians are
free ukrainians are fighting for
sovereignty and we stand by your side
and that's why we're here today
Putin's targets that were against
Ukraine's economy and the most basic
Services needs a firm response
and I think we have done a lot of good
work already in the last weeks and
months for example take the solidarity
lanes that bring Ukrainian goods and
agri-food out of Ukraine into the
European Union and into third countries
and it brings into Ukraine vital
revenues the solidarity Lanes now have
exported 20 million tons of Ukrainian
grain and food products and it has
brought back to Ukraine 15 billion euros
of vital much needed revenues for the
country so the solidarity Lanes have
really become a Lifeline for work
looking at the next year and I have very
good news because yesterday evening it
was possible to agree on 18 billion
euros for Ukraine one and a half billion
every month so a steady flow of but
direct budget support and I want to
thank you prime minister fiala for the
leadership in the negotiations as
presidency so this excellent cooperation
really yielded a big success yesterday
evening
now um besides financial support of
course there is the support in kind
we're talking about today I want to
reflect on two ways to do so the first
is what each of us can do individually
and what we can do together
on my first point let me report that the
European Union is working to increase
the amount of electricity we can trade
between Ukraine and Moldova and the rest
of Europe This is vital because we need
to keep the Ukrainian grid functioning
despite the Russian bombs
so meanwhile we have provided 40 large
generators to ensure uninterrupted power
supply to 30 hospitals in the regions of
Donetsk and yep
and Carson
these are exactly the hospitals that
need these generators because then they
are independent and keep on going with
the power supply
this comes on top of around 800
generators we are sending all across the
country right now and we all know that
this kind of assistance can literally
save lives and I know that all of you
are going the extra mileage in the
coming weeks and months to provide this
material
we have listened very carefully to the
speech of President zielinski where he
calls on the International Community to
support the purchase of 50 million LED
light bulbs
to Ukrainian households
these LED light bulbs are so vital
because they are 88 more efficient than
the old-fashioned light bulbs so an
enormous saving of energy
50 million LED light bulbs if deployed
they would save the energy that would
amount to one gigawatt of electricity
which is equivalent to the annual output
of one nuclear power plant so it's an
enormous amount of energy that can be
saved by that
um and these savings are crucial to
reduce the pressure that we have on the
Ukrainian power grid right now
therefore the commission is ready to
mobilize 30 million euros this
contribution will cover roughly 30
million LED light polyps and I hope that
others will join because in these times
literally of suffering and dark it is so
important to bring light to Ukraine
what can we do together
coordinates optimize and speed up our
support yesterday at the G7 we decided
to give the go to the Reconstruction
platform together with Ukraine and with
our International Partners the relevant
international organization and the
international financial institutions
the construction platform will start
operating already next month
the European commission together with
Ukraine will provide the Secretariat
the platform is about immediate relief
so it starts immediately with the
immediate relief and then we'll go on
with sustainable reconstruction and it
will match investment into reforms on
the pathway of Ukraine's EU membership I
want to thank all those who in the
run-up to this conference have helped so
much it starts with the conference
Lugano that we had to diagnose
the conference of experts
and that next month is up and running we
would be very happy if you send kind of
liaison officers Personnel to the
Secretariat because it's a common task
we have to deliver and we need your
expertise and the close cooperation with
all of you
final Point donations are crucial Mr
President uh Manuel you mentioned it but
we have to get them quickly to where
they are needed in a coordinated manner
right now we're working with our G7
Partners to integrate their energy
assistance into our coordination and
logistical chain for the energy
and reflecting to the Paris mechanism
I want to announce that at the heart of
the Paris mechanism we are now creating
a new Hub in Poland
which will become operational already
this week it is quite simply a network
of warehouses from which Goods can be
transferred quickly into Ukraine so this
Hub will guarantee a rapid reliable and
cost effective delivery and we are ready
to finance both the storage and the
transport than from Poland to Ukraine
be it humanitarian Aid or reconstruction
its cooperation that magnifies our
support to Ukraine I think we do learn
the lessons of these 10 months of
atrocious Russian war
Putin's world of aggression failed
mainly because of two reasons the first
one is The Bravery and the courage of
the Ukrainian people
unbelievable impressive the second one
is the international community's
remarkable Unity
so let us stay strong on this Unity let
us stand up for Ukraine and let us
literally bring light to Ukraine Slava
Ukraine
thank you very much